no
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 desde el
pasado 28 de abril colombia es escenario
de masivas manifestaciones
antigubernamentales durante las cuales
han muerto decenas de ciudadanos
víctimas de la violencia policial el uso
excesivo de la fuerza y los abusos
cometidos por los agentes están en el
centro de la polémica y también de las
denuncias el estallido que comenzó como
un rechazo a la reforma tributaria que
buscaba implementar el gobierno de bando
que no se detiene y ha ido sumando
nuevas demandas nos acompaña josé miguel
vivanco director ejecutivo de la
división de las américas de human
rightswatch señor vivanco muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
un placer estar con france24 como
siempre bueno usted ha condenado lo que
es la violencia policial durante las
manifestaciones en colombia las cifras
de muertos de heridos y de abusos varían
por supuesto según la fuente no obstante
según todas son decenas en human rights
watch que denuncias han recibido y que
pudieron confirmar
santiago nosotros tenemos un equipo de
siete investigadores que están
trabajando las 24 horas del día tratando
de rastrear documentar y corroborar las
cientos de denuncias que estamos
recibiendo todos los días sobre abusos
policiales de toda la denuncia hemos
logrado que este equipo
certificar y verificar algunas de ellas
y la cifra más reciente que tenemos
habla de 49 muertos en el contexto de
protestas
pero hemos oído de ese grupo de 49
y verificar que hay 13 casos que
directamente están son víctimas de la
violencia en las protestas de esos 13
casos hay uno que es un capitán de
policía que fue asesinado en soacha
el resto son civiles nosotros 12 casos
presumiblemente toda la evidencia
sugiere que son víctimas de brutalidad
policial algunos víctimas de armas de
fuego y otros de otro tipo de artefactos
que les han golpeado en él especialmente
en el cráneo
y ya por esas razones han muerto al
margen de eso tenemos cientos de casos
de heridos algunos de ellos graves
personas heridas en el rostro heridas de
gravedad en el resto del cuerpo
con artefactos que han sido lanzados por
la policía o es brutalmente golpeados en
el suelo al momento de la detención un
dato interesante importante santiago es
que los responsables son tanto policías
del escuadrón antidisturbios en colombia
se les conoce como el smart como también
policías regulares hemos documentado
también casos de detenciones arbitrarias
y otro tipo de abusos que estamos en
este instante verificando hablemos con
su nivel de la policía colombiana es una
fuerza que está subordinada a lo que es
el ministerio de defensa no hay una
formación para la guerra digamos y para
una actuación bajo cierta lógica de
combate al enemigo que se traslada en
este contexto a las protestas sociales
si parte del problema no el único
problema pero uno de los aspectos más
complejos del desempeño policial es que
están preparados para la guerra y han
vivido en guerra
combaten a los cárteles del narco ya las
propias guerrillas y lo siguen haciendo
que al día de hoy ese es parte de la
cultura de la preparación de la
capacitación de la policía colombiana y
por esa razón en la policía funciona
bajo el ministerio defensa creo que es
la única policía en américa latina que
no está bajo el ministerio del interior
y eso genera una percepción un trato
hacia los manifestantes que muchas veces
se traduce como el trato que se le da al
enemigo en un combate en un conflicto
armado hay varios factores adicionales
que afectan también
esta esta práctica tan brutal de
reprimir por parte de la policía y es el
hecho de que cuando tienen que rendir
cuentas por sus abusos usualmente rinden
cuentas bajo la justicia penal militar
que es muy poco transparente y donde en
los hechos
la justicia más bien deja estos estos
casos lines y de ser durante el tiempo y
no llegan a una conclusión clara y final
por eso es que es muy importante
garantizar que los abusos policiales en
colombia pasen a la justicia ordinaria y
sean examinados en esas instancias ahora
estábamos hablando no de la capacitación
que reciben no de esta suerte de lógica
militar pero hay algunos excesos que van
mucho más allá no del uso de armamento
quiero hablar en concreto de las
denuncias de casos de abusos sexuales
cometidos por partes de agente de hecho
hubo un caso emblemático no dejo el caso
de una joven de 17 años que se suicidó
luego de haber denunciado abuso sexual
por parte de agentes antidisturbios algo
que los agentes denuncian como una
noticia falsa no pero se han sumado más
denuncias sobre presuntos abusos
sexuales ahora este tipo de violencia
sexual contra las mujeres cómo se
explica
mira hemos recibido efectivamente
denuncias sobre abusos sexuales tú te
estás refiriendo al caso de la de la
mujer que es la joven que fue
aparentemente objeto de estos abusos en
popayán recientemente y que luego de ser
abusar de acuerdo
siguiente se suicidó hay una
investigación abierta por parte de la
fiscalía en este caso concreto pero
hemos recibido otros otras denuncias que
estamos verificando
nuestra experiencia no solo en colombia
sino también en el resto de la región es
que cuando existe un ambiente de
impunidad cuando no hay mecanismos
claros de fiscalización interna que
obligue a los funcionarios a comportarse
de acuerdo a los protocolos cuando la
justicia finalmente que investiga es
opaca es decir no no no no no funciona a
la luz del día como usualmente ocurre
con la justicia pero al militar sea una
serie de elementos que les permiten a
los agentes policiales creer que cuentan
con el amparo para hacer lo que se les
antoje y que jamás van a responder o
rendir cuentas respecto a estos hechos y
eso es lo que muchas veces anima también
este tipo de abuso ahora vamos a hablar
usted tuvo una respuesta por parte de la
policía el 14 de mayo mantuvo una
reunión con el general jorge luís vargas
el ex director general de la policía
nacional de colombia cuéntenos cómo fue
ese encuentro que le dijeron desde la
policía
mira tuvimos una reunión de trabajo con
el general comandante director de la
policía de colombia leal vargas el fue
bastante abierto y amable y nos recibió
con todo su equipo esta reunión fue
obviamente virtual le presentamos un
sinnúmero de casos le pusimos nuestra
preocupación que estos no eran casos
aislados que estos no eran unas cuantas
manzanas podridas que no seguían los
protocolos sino que aquí había una
práctica bastante extendida y un
problema institucional serio él no se
compartió que coincidía en que la
policía debía ser objeto de una reforma
una reforma seria especialmente lo que
tiene que ver con la disciplina interna
ese ya es un punto de progreso porque
durante todo este tiempo hemos
e impulsar esa idea y no hemos
encontrado mayor impacto en el gobierno
colombiano pero es es alentador que el
jefe de la policía coincida con que hay
que fortalecer los mecanismos de
investigación interna también le dijimos
que
a nosotros nos parecía que era muy grave
y muy delicado en argumentar que estas
protestas estaban infiltradas por el
narco por las guerrillas
en fin por por el crimen organizado sin
ofrecer las pruebas que demostraran una
denuncia tan grave como esa en ese punto
no tuvimos mayor
realmente progreso en los y sugirió que
tenían informes de inteligencia que
había algunos algunos cabecillas de
guerrillas que habían sido detenidos y
quedó en presentarnos más elementos pero
le hicimos ver lo delicado que era usar
ese argumento por que estigmatiza a
todos los que lo que salen a protestar
por último también presentamos una una
preocupación seria que tenemos y es el
hecho de que la policía muchas veces no
distingue entre aquellos que están
cometiendo delitos de vandalismo y
saqueo es decir que están haciendo
una protesta violenta y esos son delitos
que hay que prevenir y judicial izar no
distingue entre esos y los que se
manifiestan pacíficamente que son la
gran mayoría en ese punto quedamos en
seguir dialogando presentándole vídeos e
información que espero sirva para ojalá
corregir la conducta de los policías al
más breve plazo posible señor banco nos
queda poco más de minuto y medio pero no
quiero dejar de hacer una de la
siguiente pregunta no porque usted
precisamente hablaba de manzanas
podridas esto nos lleva directamente a
declaraciones del presidente iván duque
como evalúa la reacción del mandatario
respecto de la violencia policial no él
dijo entre otras cosas que las acciones
de las fuerzas públicas se están
marcando con el respeto a los derechos
humanos y que si hay violaciones por
conductas individuales dijo él se
investigan y judicial y zan
mire el presidente de duke en esto ha
estado yo diría lento no no ha estado a
la altura de la crisis de la de la
gravedad de la crisis le ha costado
mucho condenar en términos inequívocos
la brutalidad policial finalmente y muy
recientemente ha sostenido de que habrá
cero tolerancia no ha dicho es muy
importante que eso se diga por parte del
presidente frente a los abusos pero
insiste en sus pcs que son casos
aislados que son que esto nos compromete
la policía cuando la evidencia es
abrumadora y demuestra que llegue un
problema institucional serio que exige
reformas de fondo en lo que es la
preparación la capacitación los
mecanismos de fiscalización y también
por cierto los mecanismos de rendición
de cuentas por parte de las policías de
lo contrario esta situación va a
continuar lamentablemente y es probable
que se siga agravando josé miguel
vivanco muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24
a encontrar un placer estar con ustedes
no gracias estoy en nuestra audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]